[Music]
and bringing them all news submitted by
coming to Jamal iya coming couch I'm
ashes and coming angel Malia's oh yeah
I'd come there dirty girl a Chinese
woman discusses the fear of dissonant by
her parents for wanting to seek parrot
mm-hmm-hmm I read this one yeah yeah can
I do the spoiler do it she actually went
up to her parents and her parents were
like that's awesome and encouraging so
she was racist to herself she's all like
oh she's like I came out to them fearing
that they would present me and [ __ ]
kick me out of the family and they're
like that's good maybe you could get a
lot of that bottled up stuff out of your
system that's what prepare it's
basically said Jesus yeah so they're
saying here that mental health is a
silent stigma in many Asian American and
Pacific Islander cultures or a API and
so she was saying that at one point like
she needed a better way to deal with her
anxiety and depression and she hid it
from her parents because she didn't know
how they would respond and so not until
she went to therapy for four months
that's when she decided to tell her
parents about it and like Joe said they
were very supportive and she was like
wow this is weird because usually an AP
AAPI cultures it's just seen as like you
know if you're if you're expressing any
sort of sadness or anything it's like if
it's sadness then you're an attention
seeker or if you are like there's a lot
of media like for example Memoirs of a
Geisha that perpetuates tired tropes
about strong silent Asian women who in
dorm emotional pain
I thought Memoirs of a Geisha was like a
white person novel I don't know no well
I'm thinking Madame Butterfly never mind
but it said geisha no I don't know no
mores of a Geisha
yabba-doo no no I thought it was a white
person that wrote about Asian story and
pretended to make it like a but I think
that's Madame Butterfly or something
like like The Last Samurai or some [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah I think it's like that no
my dad
completely like this because he would
read stuff in the newspaper about
soldiers or military like came back that
PTSD he would just think everyone is a
[ __ ] because he's like I had to eat my
own cat so I don't know what the [ __ ]
you guys are complaining about he grew
up in a war-torn country a couple
gunshots people dying my best friend
died another 15 where you talking about
yeah so like he's so he for him it's
like because he's went through this much
stress anything that's below that he
just thinks just shut the [ __ ] up about
it that's my grandpa cuz he went to war
so it's like no matter what everyone's a
[ __ ] because I was at war but then he
doesn't realize that he has that yeah he
has me Chad he has a bad yeah the reason
why he thinks their [ __ ] is because it
makes them uncomfortable that someone's
uncomfortable yeah or no no it makes
them uncomfortable that someone's
actually seeking help when they can't
seek help themselves and they're talking
about yeah like it's a projection as
[ __ ] yeah that's true I wouldn't see
like a grandpa at your talent show like
a 1st grade talent show here like
Cummings I do [ __ ] [ __ ] that stage
if only he wouldn't go is the whole
talent shows for [ __ ] huh I mean well
also he wants to be at home drinking
is there drinking there sounds like my
dad wants to get away from those
thoughts yeah I know Forrest yeah
because drinking is his therapy exactly
and drinking and driving was his therapy
as well daivi drinking driving and blues
music absolutely drink no drinking
driving while listening like [ __ ]
taps in the Star Spangled Banner and all
of it oh yeah on full blast
this is the marching band music uh-huh
by 24/7
did there's a video of him driving with
like his best pal and they both have
their [ __ ] hats on with all the
medals on yeah yeah that's a picture
pins everywhere and they're blasting
like [ __ ] all these Marine Corps
March they drive around like it's a
[ __ ] straight up parade like during a
break and they drive it slower and Abreu
can walk faster than his cars booty oh
my god but do they have a homie in the
back of the convertible doing I wish
that's the only thing that's missing is
waiting that's the only thing they
weren't doing that was probably like the
happiest time of his life so he has to
keep tapping into that yeah that's crazy
Wow it is true though in I think Asian
culture if you need to go to a therapist
they're like what's wrong with you are
you a psychopath
mmm-hmm like are you are you about to
like mass murder some people like what's
really going on through Scientology is
like mm-hmm
you're not doing that [ __ ] yeah no you
got to go to the e meter and check your
[ __ ] even I'm gonna go to the e
meter do the same [ __ ] that psychology
is just go to our people you know it's
amazing
that's like plant others sharing your
head mm-hmm exactly
yes so yeah like so this girl she's just
talking about her experience and also
how a lot of API women in particular
feel that they have been conditioned by
their cultures to remain silent about
depression and they can experience low
self-esteem dude like because they
aren't able to meet the familial and
often sexist expectations and so it's
just a really interesting piece on on
like mental health and AAPI people I
mean isn't this a lot of cultures that a
lot of ethnicities yeah it's margin I
didn't grow up with that like I grew up
like if you well first of all that I
don't I did no one speaks depression
like that word I feel like just kind of
surfaced in the English world
yeah like it just kind of came out of
nowhere and I'm like what is this whole
thing about depression like I would see
my mom struggle or whatever but like she
bet she internalized a lot of it so it
wasn't something that we would
like I would see her eyes get teary or
whatever but she didn't have like the
circle of friends either that she would
talk to you like it was just one of
those things where it's like well that's
just life and you can't just gotta move
on and it wasn't like oh god I got to
seek some help because there's some
[ __ ] Hobbit doing in our culture too
it's like instead of seeking an actual
like professional therapist like we
speak to a lot of family members at
least in my family and you're like for
sure my family is of the truth like
they're probably even more [ __ ] up or
just as [ __ ] up as you are you can't
really get anywhere because you're stuck
in that same little cycle everyone
getting bad advice yeah it's like
getting drunk like let's just go out
that way yeah I think the point of this
piece wasn't necessary to say that just
Asians have like a problem going to
therapy you're just pointing out like
how they don't have as much resources
and all that not to exclude like
Hispanics or anything else but that's
sure that it's more of a white thing I
guess to be accepted not that every
because like we see your granddad dude I
think depression was real until a couple
years ago I was like that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
but it is more available to white
communities and it's not as that bad
oh yeah cuz they it is mentioned here
how like for example for her it was
really hard to find another like Asian
therapist to talk to so they actually
understand like the cultural struggles
that go behind like the stigma of
talking about mental health and so
that's what you're getting in Riley
you're kind of yeah there's limited
resources because it's mainly white
there yeah even in the culture they're
not talking about it so then they're not
gonna of course go and become a
therapist yeah like why are you studying
this thing that won't even talk about no
it's not even available for people who
do want to break out of that mold and
seek help and all those do when it comes
to guys who are like I have depression
my reflux is just your [ __ ] like you
know yeah it's bad I know that that's
bad but it's just my reflexes like that
now individually if I was to talk to
somebody if David was the last time you
checked off and they're like yesterday I
might you don't depression you [ __ ]
live sex [ __ ] nice like I haven't jacked
off in a month I'm like oh my god you're
in trouble
I see
you're big trouble young man so the more
Jack jacking off you do the less
depressed you are because I know how
happy he was just five minutes that make
sense to me five minutes ago I actually
think the more people jerk off the more
the best yeah but it's really hard to
like watch porn when you're like up for
me I'm just like I'm so sad and I look
at it and I'm like I am you don't get it
here do there's there's no like nothing
comes out of it I think I think guys are
different though
Joe got sad for like a few months and he
wasn't jacking off as much yeah so I cuz
you're driving me crazy religion theory
is correct if it's been a month he's
actually really I'm correct again Steve
so that's my thing though I think a lot
of people use it lean on jerking off for
dopamine for sure and when they're
depressed but but yeah when it comes to
an individual like if David soul is to
come to me and be like yo man I have
depression then it's not [ __ ] because
I'm talking to an individual when I hear
like that a group of guys has depression
I am reflexively think yeah that's true
cuz I always question it like are you
saying that as a cop-out or are you
saying that because you really are yeah
it shouldn't matter sure because
everyone's experience is different
someone can get depressed because of
[ __ ] they got a bad grade and then
stay in depression for a long long time
yeah and then what I realize is that
it's not the trigger that matters it Y
is that trigger exists they don't they
don't have healthy mental coping skills
for everyday life so it's more like how
do I just help this person like point
them more towards healthy coping skills
yeah I mean cuz probably very like a
smaller number of people who actually
have like what is it what's the word I'm
thinking I don't mean yeah like their
brain chemicals are actually [ __ ] up
and they have like no chance like they
need pills yeah that's probably a lot
smaller than most people it's just that
we're not connecting we're not like you
know actually thought that I was one of
those people that I just had a chemical
imbalance
my mind because pretty much pull it
early like my entire life I felt
surprised yeah somebody in bounces yeah
a lot and so what are you tired I
thought she was sleeping
oh no but um but yeah so not until
recently did I discover like and you
hear these things but it never [ __ ]
isn't like right there are cliques but
then like recently I it clicked on my
head where I'm like oh like I really did
put myself in this prison of depression
because of my own expectations they're
like whatever the [ __ ] it was like I
mean how did you get out of it though is
probably because people are helping you
like your friends community yeah you can
you know you're so important because I
mean I have been going to therapy too
and it's just really hard to get any
progress because it's like one hour a
week and they cost so much money I don't
believe in therapy [ __ ] that [ __ ] I mean
I'm sure like it would have helped me in
the long run but then I would have been
very broke but luckily like I'm blessed
enough to have you guys in my life and
you guys helped me get out of it you
guys are [ __ ] awesome social support
works way better than therapy in my
opinion you look at Maslow's hierarchy
of needs if you knock down everything
going up to the list that [ __ ] works way
better than [ __ ] going into therapy
sessions because if you don't have
social support if you don't work on
yourself physically and/or all those
things and all you do is see a therapist
and pop pills all day it'll never it
will be a never-ending cycle there's
something cool to having people around
you who are genuinely invested in what
you're going through right and not
somebody who's transactionally there it
was really hard to like yes and to go
through the real process you need hours
of continuous like like five hours talk
it out cuz it takes a while to even
understand why like what you're trying
to say or what's really behind what
you're saying you know how you kept
telling me like it's really important to
ask yourself like why and why and get in
the deeper levels I never clicked like I
couldn't understand that there's no
white and tigers [ __ ] you but Potamus
exactly like my mind goes there cuz
until you learn everybody do you
learning how to ride the bike actually
doing by doing it it's wrong like now
it's like oh this just easy now like now
I know why this bothers me because of
this thing and this thing and this thing
in
here's the route that I remember you
asked the same question to when you're
like oh how do you get into like topics
in history and like I go I go down a
rabbit hole like a [ __ ] I
investigate yeah and you're like oh I
don't go past like the second question
and then I didn't you said something
like you feel stupid so you just not
bother with it anyway I always put
myself down because I never gave myself
enough credit to believe that I had it
in me to even continue to vote yeah
you're like oh this is hard
and then you're like I rather not think
about it because I feel you know stupid
for not knowing but it's it's actually
the opposite you know you can cure your
stupidity by just knowing more exactly
dude talking to different I was like
she's just joined a cult dude for sure
though I definitely see a new new soul
in this person by huge yeah it's like a
squeal so [ __ ] right right doing you
know more confidence and just vibrance
out of you - yeah it really does [ __ ]
feel like I was trapped in a void
depression pretty much my whole [ __ ]
life and then like somehow like you guys
you guys like literally like reach down
and I'm like give me your hand and they
pull you almost big time yeah slavery
that's how you pay back yeah yeah hold
on before we even get there before you
in the video this is kind of important
too so Casey and I had a conversation
right about like we discovered which
I'll get deeper tomorrow when we talk
but we discovered this thing where he
felt like he wanted to create his own
doors to walk through like opportunities
and I felt that I wasn't worthy enough
or like I felt like I owed it to every
door that I've ever walked through and I
never gave myself credit but Casey was
like but no one creates their own doors
like doors are there and people just
walk through them right so like we have
to give enough credit to like at least
for me I have to give enough credit to
myself that I walked through that door
like you guys were that door for me to
walk through to get out of depression
whoo I'm getting emotional and then for
him he's like I have to humble myself in
order to like walk myself through that
door and because we just kept ignoring
the doors you know
ah but ya know you could you could thank
me for everything
[Applause]
[Music]